pleasure trap you know what inspired you
want to write this book i mean obviously
it's done very well i'm looking at the
reviews
what what inspired you want to write
this book well you know we've been in
practice a long time before we started
writing the pleasure trap and the idea
was to try to
explain how it was these patients that
we were seeing get well
were actually getting well trying to
come up with a an explanation that made
sense that was consistent with our
experience
and the facts as as we could determine
them and so
you know in our mind the pleasure trap
that is the artificial stimulation of
doping in your brain
uh that dopamine is what's associated
with pleasure the more
dopamine the more pleasure the more
dopamine the better the
food tastes the more the better the
experience
is perceived the reason why your brain
gives you dopamine
is to reinforce behaviors that favor
survival and reproduction
so it's not surprising that the only
natural normal stimulants of dopamine
are food and sex food and sex are the
only
natural normal intense stimulants of
dopamine as you'd expect because if you
didn't engage in enough feeding behavior
you wouldn't survive
if you didn't engage in enough sexual
behavior you wouldn't survive
and so it's it's logical that the body
would the brain would reward the body
by engaging in these uh positive
behaviors the problem was humans got
really clever
and we learned to short circuit this
very natural system with the use of
certain chemicals
and one of the most obvious are drugs
alcohol cocaine
uh methamphetamines these chemicals all
stimulate dopamine production and make
people feel good the problem is it's an
it's an unnatural stimulation and so it
can lead to addiction i mean that's the
hallmark of addiction
we're having to do something to continue
not only to feel good but to avoid
feeling very bad
you know the withdrawal effect and the
same thing happens when you have these
chemicals
into the diet they taste really good
they make foods taste good because they
result in dopamine stimulation in the
brain just like that drugs do
but it's an artificial stimulation and
you can literally develop
an addiction if you will to the
artificial stimulation of these
chemicals and now you have to keep
eating these chemicals to avoid feeling
very bad
and people don't like to think of
themselves as addicts because they're
eating a sugar
salt and oil rich diet but the reality
is when they try to stop it it's very
difficult
and that's why today two-thirds of
people are overweight or obese
you know the majority of people are
developing these chronic degenerative
diseases
and people are dying um and becoming
debilitated which was maybe even a
bigger issue years before
um they passed you know life expectancy
up until recently had continued to
increase the last few years it's
actually
starting to decrease and even perhaps
more important or
urgent to people than life expectancy
that is how long they're going to live
on average
is healthy life expectancy how well
they're going to live when they're alive
the reality is 9.6 years of ability is
average now so people are not living a
good life and then having a good death
where they go to bed and
and don't wake up they're spending years
or decades unable to talk or move lying
in nursing home beds waiting for people
to come and change their diaper
because they've had strokes or heart
attacks or preventable debilitating
illnesses
and that's what we're interested in
helping our patients prevent we know
they're not going to live forever look
it
you have 109 billion modern humans that
have been born on the planet there's
about
7.7 billion of us alive today but we
only have good documentation of
five people living past 117.
you're not going to live forever you
have a 1 in 20 billion chance of living
past 117 currently
so you know you're not living forever
but what you don't want to do
is give up what could be the richest
most valuable
years of your life the last 10 or 20
years of your life
give them up essentially because of
short-term pleasure
self-indulgent behavior that leads you
into becoming debilitated unnecessarily
yeah we want people to live their full
life potential and take advantage of
that
you